[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
okay I watched this episode twice yeah
we watched it last night and I took
notes on it and then he watched it again
just like right before the show okay got
murdered in here what's up bro
he said they needed to hurry and do the
surgery on his toe it's killing him yeah
that sucks needs to be a approval
they're doing all kinds of [__] to that
dude really yeah not just his towel
that sucks I mean I guess it's good that
it's getting done but yeah sucks because
you have to go through all that stay on
that test man
I don't know if that helped your toe out
but you know took a lot of weight off of
him
looking younger
Yeah well yeah should have strengthened
you yeah
and so so long all the problems you have
will catch up with you and just [__]
pester you for the rest of your life
that's the spirit yes
now at least you'll be able to heal up
yeah he's like I'm 100 years old I can't
[__] yeah so uh right before right
before we started streaming
uh Thomas just watched this episode
again and he's like I'm not really sure
I got anything more out of it the second
time yeah it's written it's kind of a
jumble it jumps around some this was it
wasn't a bad episode though I thought it
wasn't bad I thought it was kind of
creepy
it's movie like
they all started going like that in
season five we keep mentioning that I'm
trying I was trying to pick through
what was actual and what it was they
were just showing you know what I mean
for for effect and
um trying to trying to divide up what
they actually physically saw happen the
phenomena and what they thought happened
or what they felt which that's
hard to prove what somebody felt you
know what I mean it's hard to prove what
somebody saw yeah I saw this but you
weren't nobody else saw it you know so
I'm just trying to go through them but
it's a good case
in some ways it's kind of like my case
in a way where it's about a woman who
had an NDA nde a near-death experience
and when she came back out of it
she basically became a medium
and uh unwittingly
a lot of reports of that
but I had weird paranormal type [__]
happen to me before my nde afterwards
actually after the nde it kind of
chilled out it's still around Jenny's
seen it it's just not as strong but part
of the reason why I think it got weaker
was
you get older I think it has a lot to do
with it
there's something about
being young helps it
but I kind of feel like
um this episode I don't know if it was
unique because I'm sure that there was
other ones that had this particular
angle but I did like the angle of the
woman who was clinically dead she was
she it wasn't even a near-death
experience she was dead yeah yeah they
pronounced her dad yeah
um and she was dead for quite a while
and then she came back to life yeah she
didn't have an out-of-body experience no
she said she didn't see anything she
said it was just darkness that's what my
dad said when he uh had started having
those heart attacks up in the hospital
and they shocked him back alive and I
said did you uh See the Light did you go
up there and he goes nine seen nothing
nothing but just Oblivion
Oblivion
[Laughter]
there's nothing
don't there's something you just wait
that's what this woman says you know she
said she didn't see anything yeah
because she said a lot of people ask her
and she was dead for more than five
minutes yeah so my dad was always kind
of like he was never a church-going guy
but he always believed in God and Jesus
and [__] and that he went to heaven got
it until he had started having those
heart attacks and [__] diet and then
shocking it back they're just Oblivion
he was disappointed yeah yeah I was like
no man if I cannot you know says I'm not
all religious and I had the whole out of
body experience and the [__] whole
Entourage waiting for me and [__]
people I knew and the big [__]
counselor who's [__] telling you now
you got to go back you know
you still got [__] to do yeah
I wonder what it was that he wanted you
to do he showed me but I wasn't allowed
to remember they said that he says
what's the point of that because the
reason we're reasoning with you right
then you're going oh okay it makes sense
to you at the time but you can't you
weren't allowed to remember us because
it was spoiled a mission
so you're not like exposed to because
it'll mess up if you know what your
future is right yeah I gotcha because
then you might like and you wouldn't
choose unwittingly like [__] it up right
by trying not to do it or trying to like
make an end run and do it and like yeah
based on what I was shown there's like
predestiny there's things that you have
to do in order to complete the creation
you got side missions and all that kind
of stuff like a video game well it's
funny you know they were showing me the
life's life of woven and all these
tapestries and [__] you said yeah Neil
Gaiman wrote a book like that I [__]
no Clive Barker I Barker okay weave
world yeah it had I had never heard of
that but that's that's what I'd probably
like that book it's Kick-Ass that's
that's that's what I saw
it it was weird that lives were all
interwoven like a damn temperature like
yeah it was it was like a literal yeah
tapestry or like a literal card right
but it was like a it made a singularity
that was kind of like outside you know
time was in it and I was outside of time
and I was seeing this Singularity this
creation and it had to be executed I
need to reread that book now I was
thinking about it yeah I have it
someplace
Pookie probably tore it up on the bottom
but uh but yeah it was I remember it was
being really good but like I said you
probably dig it it's very long though I
mean all of Clive Barker's books are
pretty long
he's uh he's one for writing them
chunkers man yeah the door stops but uh
yeah murder Hornet said I've heard of
people not saying anything yeah so have
I it seems like I don't even know what
the percentage is of people that have
like technically like died and come back
to life like on the operating table or
whatever
um it's like it's just a certain
percentage of people that see like the
whole light and the your dead family
members and all that other kind of stuff
and I don't even know if it's a majority
maybe it's just half and half I remember
like seeing some kind of statistic at
some point but I can't remember what it
was but I remember it being like not as
high as I was expecting the reports of
the experience are pretty consistent no
matter what the religion is or lack
thereof that it might have like
Christian overtones or Islamic styling
or judaic type styling and or even like
Buddhist you know depending on what
you're but if you don't have any of
those kind of beliefs it's still kind of
like that same kind of thing
well see I always you know the what the
skeptic would say then is that well that
means that it comes somehow from like
the structure of the brain it's like
making you see
same kind of things and you're just like
slightly interpreting it in the way that
your culture would dictate
I would disagree I'm just saying it
seems very hyper realistic it was real
you know
it was just uh
like a little process
I didn't go I didn't go down some tunnel
or up some tunnel a [__] tunnel of
[__] light came down and got me
tunnel of chili
it's like a big ball of light boom came
down and got me and then I was somewhere
else
it was in a whole sea of light it was
like welding Arc and all the people were
kind of made out of welding arcs but
they were they were like little icons
that were frozen kind of faces you could
see them but there was just thought you
could kind of you could pick up their
thoughts so well you could kind of hear
what their voices and their tone their
tone of their voice was supposed to be
but there was like images at the same
time when they're speaking to you
and if you wanted to see what they look
like or what or whatever icon or
whatever Avatar they wanted to appear as
it would get a little bit more clear but
it wasn't in color it was just Prismatic
white light like a like a welding Arc
but it was 3D
and so was the background so it was hard
it doesn't make any sense when you're
describing it
you're not seeing it with eyes you're
seeing it with uh some you know your
soul I guess
yeah it's like you're swimming in a
[__] 3D sea of static and the Statics
made out of welding arcs it's kind of
Prismatic white yeah I can picture that
yeah
uh when you're floating in a vast space
yeah 360 degrees of it you know and
there's just things around you murder
Hornet said nde is one of his favorite
subjects yes
it is kind of it is kind of interesting
I read a whole um book about it well
it's I've read several books about it
usually from a skeptical point of view
but I find that interesting too like you
know even if it's not anything like it's
interesting that the brain does that
weird kind of [__] so this woman though
seems to have not had a super pleasant
experience after like I said it wasn't
technically an nde because she was dead
like for a while that's still near death
I guess so he came back she did come
back and we were I wonder they didn't
bring this up on the show but one of the
things she just went in for it was an
appendectomy right like an emergency she
had happened to repented her but it's
taken out and they gave her like the
nurse I guess like [__] up and gave
her like an overdose of sedative or
something like that and it killed her
yeah and like I said she was dead for
five minutes I think they said five
minutes and 42 seconds they pronounced
her dead because they tried to bring her
back and it didn't work and then they
were like well let's fill out the
paperwork we lost another one they were
all like Cavalier about it but then like
she just kind of like popped back into
and we were sitting there going lawsuit
but they didn't say anything about that
no I'm sure she got a check I would hope
so yeah because she like yeah I'd be
like what you came and more to it than
that
have given her some antidotes and
[__] you know in terms of like uh
some [__] methamphetamine or
something to get her heart started yeah
maybe maybe they did a Pulp Fiction yeah
put a bunch of adrenaline in her mouth
and [__] [__] [__] shock her ass
back I wonder if it was because in the
in the episode they just made it seem
like like they did a bunch of stuff like
clear and all that kind of stuff and it
didn't work and she was still like
flatlined and they're like oh well and
then they're like okay pronounce her dad
at whatever time it was and then like
all of a sudden they had stopped working
on her and then she's like you know what
I mean and then she like wakes up but I
don't know if that's really what it was
you could be dead for a long time
evidently under the right conditions and
come back there were people kids have
drowned in near freezing water and been
down there for like 45 minutes they
bring them up and they're dead they've
been dead for 40 45 minutes they bring
them back yeah but but it's under a very
very narrow set of parameters like
usually it has to be like super super
cold water
they had one it's a little kid I think
it was a little toddler escaped from the
house
yeah Tyler escaped from the house in the
middle of the night they don't know why
he's just a toddler escape from the
house in the middle of the night when
it's freezing cold outside snow and went
out there in the [__] PJs
they found
that toddler Frozen like [__] rock
solid
and uh
they don't know how long it was out
there if they thought him out just put
him alive so he came back
I saw a uh a video of somebody that
found a frozen kitten yeah the same
thing and they and the kitten was fine
yeah after they thawed the kitten out
and everything like that
was and didn't seem like nothing wrong
with it they did they just kept it weird
like I said if it's well that's why they
went all in on that whole like
freezing thing
um because
to an extent but I see I don't really
know I don't know what the state of the
art is with that nowadays like you know
with the freezing heads and like once
you bring them back and stuff like that
I'm not saying they wouldn't be able to
do that one of these days but that does
seem to be there was one that I heard I
don't know if it's true I just heard
about it I think it was on radio might
have been an art bell and it's hard to
know what was right yes sir I don't know
how much stock I put in that this is
probably around
2005 Maybe
um some Japanese girl
froze
I don't remember how
she was drunk or something I fell asleep
outside and and died of [__] exposure
[__] man that's some [__] you got to
worry about yeah up in [__] Minnesota
and [__] and she had evidently been dead
a long time
hours six seven hours and uh they took
her to the emergency room
you know once they found her and the
doctor's like no she's she's dead it's
like no way and what somebody there was
like no let's just try to bring her back
and they just put her out of a
ventilator come on far out put her on a
ventilator they were ventilating giggles
ventilating her logs and put a warm
blanket on her and she came back
and she didn't have anything wrong with
her yeah evidently nothing wrong with
her but she had been she was drunk I
think and if I remember correct she was
drunk and died of exposure fell asleep
outside [__] freezing cold wow she
had a great [__] story did she have
been out there for a long time I wonder
if she drank again after that I don't
know
I might not
and then they were postulating well how
many people could have been saved if
they just put them on a ventilator right
yeah like I said if they've been dead
like in [__] Florida it wouldn't be
the same they're probably dead but um
yeah but like I said Minnesota in the
middle of winter or something like that
give it a whirl you never know that's
what the doctor said right he says let's
just it can't hurt anything yeah just
ventilator put her on there and right
we'll put a warm blanket on her see what
happens
and like 30 40 minutes later she she
came to she's like what the [__] can you
imagine them like telling her that how
would you yeah how would you react like
if you woke up and you're like where the
[__] am I it's like the last thing I
remember I was [__] drinking if
somebody can find that story man drop it
in the comment section I just remember
it I think it was 2004 right they were
like yo baby you've been dead for like
45 minutes it was more than that it was
an unbelievable amount of time we're
talking like three four hours
which that's crazy yeah that's crazy she
probably didn't remember [__] about [__]
I imagine
I I think she was drunk when she passed
out that makes sense and then froze
because you do dumb [__] when you're
drunk I'm just gonna walk home
I don't care if it's 30 below and then
she's like oh this was a stupid idea it
was in the winter in Japan
I don't know if it was in the city it's
part of the country
uh Zach said uh legit though I have to
wonder what happens to you if you've
been dead that long
yeah I mean I guess if you're Frozen and
preserved I guess nothing much but it
would be I don't know that would weird
me out like because if they told her
later would say like hey you were dead
for four hours or however long it was
it's like man I would just never stop
thinking about that that would be
[__] freaky
I'll be like Oh I'm like a real life
zombie it makes you kind of like
consider yourself a robot
okay yeah well kind of like a machine
that can be turned off and on and when
it turned back on you're like okay no
but no problem I'm working
it kind of goes against my experience
but I kind of believe that Stuart
hammeroff says it's Quantum particles in
a in a field the quantum Soul Theory
it's giving you the experience of koalia
or the the feeling of existing
and uh anesthesia will take that away
person will be walking and talking and
intelligent passing intelligence tests
and everything
they're not conscious though
and when it wears off they don't
remember anything it happened to Jenny
it Jay came up out of anesthesia and she
was talking normally she didn't remember
any of it she was just uh she was Jenny
she wasn't quite as
um active you know what I mean like she
wouldn't
she would respond but she wouldn't start
conversations that went on for probably
about an hour
and uh yeah because the the thing the
first thing I remember I don't remember
waking up I don't remember walking out
into the recovery room I don't remember
anything the first thing I remember is
you putting me in the car yeah so I
don't know how yeah like I remember that
and I sort of remember riding home in
the car and I remember you putting me in
bed and bringing me a sandwich I
remember that but it's like I don't
remember anything about no I remember
waking up in the recovery room for a
second and being like really freezing
cold yeah and I remember that the nurse
had told me that's why they tell you
when you go to surgery it's like oh wear
socks and a sweater and stuff even a
thought outside because when you wake up
like the anesthesia will usually make
you look really really cold and I
remember being really cold and I thought
she brought me a blanket but I don't
that's all I remember from being we were
talking we were holding whole
conversations and stuff which is crazy
because I don't remember any of it yeah
nothing well it's because you were the
the anesthesia shuts down those
microtubules inside the inside the
neurons
and the little Quantum particles don't
flow down there correctly so you you go
from a quantum computer a quantum
computer to more of a digital computer
like a laptop
you could do a lot of [__] but you don't
have a sense of koala you have a sense
of being
which which is funny I don't it makes
you wonder why why living creatures need
a sense of koalia
because they would work just fine
without a sense of Consciousness well it
might not there's something it might be
an emergent property yeah I mean it
might not it might have just happened do
you think that like without cause there
could be aliens that do not have any any
sense of being yeah they're just a
machine a living machine Maybe
murder Hornet said like me on Ambien
yeah yeah I've heard that I've heard
some stories about Ambien any kind of
will you get up and make a whole meal
and eat a whole thing in the middle of
the night without remembering it kind of
anesthesia turns you into a robot it's
like that's [__] crazy you go from I
to AI yeah it's crazy yeah
Zach said uh oh Jesus I just tried
looking up that story and find an
article about an office worker who died
from overwork after 159 hours of
overtime in a month holy [__]
that's depressing Zach you trying to
find the Japanese girl that froze yeah I
guess yeah it may not be true yeah I
mean that's I mean but well yeah but I
have heard about stories I don't know
about three or four hours but I have
heard about people that like because I
remember hearing about a kid I don't I
think it was a little boy but maybe not
and I think he either like broke through
the ice or something like that he
drowned in like a really really cold
Pond and he was down there for a while
it wasn't four hours about 90 minutes I
think yeah I think it was like an hour
or something like that and um and he was
revived and he was fine like he didn't
have any brain damage or anything it's
because of that low temperature the
brain doesn't rot yeah and it just kind
of like goes it seems to go into
suspended animation I don't think it
always works because no they die
sometimes because sometimes they just
die but every now and then like I said
you might as well if you find like a
like a human popsicle you might as well
like [__] yeah try to bring it back
yeah it doesn't hurt anything and I
don't think there will be and they might
appreciate it I don't think there'll
ever be any reliable suspended animation
like you see in the science fiction
movies for space travel you might be
able to do that for a few hours but you
wouldn't be able to do that for months
and years like they're talking about
I think that would like [__] you up yeah
well I would think I don't think it
would it wouldn't work out I mean the
human body is more complicated real
complicated it is very complicated and
the thing about it is like I don't know
it's like really complicated and it's
also like it's really resilient but it's
also like kind of delicate in a lot of
ways too like you can't [__] with it too
much well it would be a lot better
we're getting way off topic okay will it
be a lot better what else is suspended
animation
is just to have a bunch of damn
fertilized eggs in there and before the
ship gets to the destination it grows
all those eggs in a [__] synthetic
womb and raises in a robot raises them
all his children and educates them so
they arrive about when they arrive to
their destination they're about 15 years
old and they're fully trained that's
that's how you do it well yeah probably
have to be adults when they leave they
could be unborn well the thing about it
too is that would probably be better for
their mental health yeah they wouldn't
know any different would know that
they're just like oh this is life you
know I mean like they wouldn't know they
wouldn't have to wait that [__] 200
years or [__] 50 years of Journey
that would be their idea yeah and then
it'd be just a [__] real good android
robot that [__] acts like Mom and Dad
to them and you know explains to them
that you guys are different than where
you came from this is a space mission
you're the best jeans we could possibly
get you're all genetically engineered
Superman you're going to colonize this
new planet
murder Hornet said set Tom a 55 gallon
drum of Astro glad
what's that
Noob yes movies yeah
he's trying to get me to do that a in a
Lube photo
[Laughter]
Zach
sent me from [__] Tom Hardy's [__]
old MySpace Myspace page dude had back
arch like a female porn star is she was
driving better than that better yeah he
was Jenny's like God damn but uh he he
was like wow he's flexible he was doing
he was trying his hardest to get cast
he's gonna get get work in Hollywood
well it works
that butt angle that was something else
I didn't
think that was even possible crazy
I mean he's probably really good at
twerking
he's a twerk master I'm sure twerk
Master twerk Master twerk Master British
twerk master
Zach says Jesus Christ the ungodly
things I do if I walked into a room and
found that
let's just served right up there it's
reserved right up on a bladder all right
so should we should we talk about this
show now before people start getting mad
please I mean nobody seems to be getting
mad but you know I'm always kind of like
well if I title it that then probably we
should talk about it yeah like at some
point talk about this case I'm gonna
talk about this case yeah well I mean we
kind of were talking about it because we
talked about because she was dead they
were talking about ndes and [__] yeah
which this does kind of like revolve
around that yeah
so uh so yeah so this happened in 2005.
this was this is season five episode ten
I think it was yeah Called Death store
in case we didn't uh mention that so
this happened in 2005 in Lafayette
Indiana now the woman's name is here's
what's weird her name is Victoria and
then I thought on the show that the
narrator said her last name was denier
but when I looked it up on Wikipedia it
just says that her last name is Dane so
I'm like okay I don't so I don't know
who's right
so she's like a single mom and she has a
daughter named Anna I don't think they I
mean Anna's like factors into it a
little bit they didn't say how old she
was but I guess it doesn't really matter
so
um so basically she's got like a
full-time job she's also finishing a
master's degree at Purdue which so she's
very busy as you can see
so one morning in June of 2005.
um as we mentioned earlier she has to
have an emergency appendectomy
and one of the nurses [__] up and ODS
her on like pain meds or like mixes two
together that aren't supposed to be
mixed or something like that and it
essentially kills her and they do
pronounce her dad so she's dead for they
said five minutes and 42 seconds
but then after that she wakes back up
and then probably the nurses were like
please don't sue us you know what I mean
but I would have sued them anyway just
saying
um yeah so she wakes up and obviously
she didn't know where she was and they
she said she didn't see anything like I
said she didn't see a light or a tunnel
or none of that [__] she said she was
just nothing it was just darkness
so she actually recovers pretty quickly
so 24 hours later they let her go back
home and she's fine she said she even
had enough energy to like go back to the
house and do some [__] spring
cleaning and [__] like that
so she goes up to the attic and starts
straightening up up there this is a
rented house I should note
so in this little cubby in the Attic she
finds these two boxes which do not
belong to her she doesn't know whose
they are
one of the boxes has like a bunch of
military uniforms and stuff like that in
it and then the second box had like a
like a remote control like a toy
helicopter yeah and it wasn't one of the
nice ones it was one of the cheap ones
you get like a 7-Eleven yeah yeah like
yeah I've seen those yeah they're like
the ten dollar ones yeah it was just
little it was like a little black thing
so she brings it out and she says to her
daughter she says look at this neat
thing that I found up in the attic like
I don't know who this was and there's no
batteries in the remote control very
clearly however the helicopter turns on
by itself like the little she said the
little light started flashing on it and
the um propeller started going around
like really really fast it didn't like
take off it didn't seem like but it just
kind of like spun like around on the
coffee table yeah
and the daughter's like what the [__]
she's like I thought you said there were
no batteries so they like checked again
and there's no batteries and they're
like what um okay I don't know maybe
it's just like some kind of weird glitch
or something yeah like that instead yeah
I mean well what what would you think I
mean you know what I mean that it would
just come on by itself like that so
she's like it did that for a couple of
minutes and then it just like stopped I
think they're making a mistake
they said there was no battery those
that type of helicopter they were
showing does not have a detachable
battery it's a permanently installed
battery that you recharge by hooking a
charging cable into it okay so maybe
they were looking for a battery that
comes out
no battery comes out of that there's
just a charging port on the side of it
and maybe there was a little bit of
charge left in it that battery might
have been somebody fully charged it
maybe months prior maybe yeah we have a
small amount of charge left and they put
it on a table and somebody maybe hit hit
the switch and turn the switch on
and or the switch is almost on and
setting it down it slowly kind of turned
on and that would cause the lights to
flash because when you turn them on the
lights Flash
and then maybe there was some kind of
glitch in the thing and it it you know I
mean the rotors started moving well
that's not enough to lift not enough
that's what they thought too it might
have been real weak you know the battery
was real weak because it'd been sitting
in there for months
or however long I don't know they
weren't real clear about how long that
her and the daughter have been living in
this house like I said it is rented
they're renting it but I don't know how
long they've been living there yeah I'd
have to see their phenomenon myself yeah
I'm sure they dramatized it for the
thing because on the show they made it
seem like it was like spinning around
flashing and blah blah and maybe it
wasn't that I'm sure but not been that
dramatic but they said there's no
battery in it right well yeah if you're
expecting there to be a double A in
there no
it's a it's an onboard little built-in
battery it's small
so there's no there's no place to remove
it it's in there forever so the remote
control doesn't have a battery in it it
does the remote control does but but not
the but not the not the helicopter right
I got it there's a there's a charging
cable that comes off the remote control
and you plug it into the side of the
helicopter and it'll sit there and reach
like a full charge in about 15 minutes
and it'll fly for like 30 seconds
yeah okay
that's it well Fun's over yeah Fun's
over now we get now we gotta charge it
again right so that thing may have been
for another 30 seconds so there's no
battery yeah there's no battery no
battery you can remove
so I think they're they're [__]
they're playing a game with us there
of course there's a battery in there
it's built in
murder Hornet said why even tell her she
died avoid the lawsuit altogether she
was none the wiser yeah that's true yeah
I was like
maybe that happens all the time and
they're like
damn they were dead we're gonna get
[__] sued yeah I don't yeah I don't
even know why they by the way you were
dead because I I don't know if there
wasn't really any reason to tell them
then I guess there really isn't any
reason to tell you I'm not sure if I'd
want to know or not to be honest with
you
maybe I would but I'm not really sure
I've never been in that situation so I
don't know but um but yeah so informed
the family that she died huh maybe they
had informed formed the family that she
had died well I don't think it had been
that long I don't think it had got to a
thing because usually it's a thing where
they had only just I mean at least
according to the reenactment I don't
know how accurate this was but they had
only just pronounced her dead right but
see I yeah I thought they worked on you
longer than that like before they were
actually like well we give up you know
what I mean fill out the [__] death
certificate but
maybe they just knew or they were like
ah we're tired it's in the shift
maybe I don't know
um
you know so uh so yeah so Victoria calls
up the landlord the lady that owns the
house that they live in
and ask where this stuff in the Attic
came from she's like whose [__] is this
this is like the old residence that they
left here or something like that but the
landlord said I don't know where it came
from like you know so I don't know if
she if it she knew that it belonged to
the old people that lived there or
whatever she's like I don't know where
it came from so Victoria is like well
I'm just gonna put all this [__] back in
the boxes and stick it right back where
I found it and I'm just like not gonna
worry about it anymore which is probably
the best thing to do you know all things
considered
three weeks later in the middle of the
night
the TV comes on by itself like out in
the living room
so Victoria's sleeping and a sleeping
and then so it comes on and it starts
like flipping through all the channels
like it was pretty creepy like the way
they did it on the show like every now
and then they showed me like you know
it'd be like uh you know here's a TV
show and here's another TV show and
demon face and then there's another TV
show and then another demon patient yeah
so I don't know if that's what really
happened or not but she just said that
TV kept coming on by itself
so she could like she goes in there and
she's like what the [__] and she's like
looking at it and then
um it turned off
and then because like Anna came down
it's like what the hell is going on down
here and like the TV went off and then
she's like okay whatever so she goes
back in her room and then five minutes
later she said it did the same thing
like it turned the TV turned on the
living room again and then she went out
there and when she went out there to
look at it like it turned itself off
again
um so she's like okay and again she's
still trying to like think maybe this is
maybe it's power surges or something
like that now we had the TV come on by
itself all the time at our old house all
the time and it wasn't always the same
TV
no it wasn't a couple times it's in the
bedroom yeah usually it was the living
room TV but not always like sometimes it
was a bedroom now it didn't flip through
channels or nothing like that it would
go on a screensaver it would go to like
this screensaver yeah that was weird
which is really weird but yeah it
happened like pretty much like every
second or third day like I would get up
in the morning I was making my coffee
before going to work and I'd be like oh
let's see [__] TV's on it'd be a
month that it wouldn't happen
and then it would do it regularly for
about a month and they would remember
that like every couple of days yeah and
then like then it would then it would
stop for a couple months three four
months and then do it again for like a
couple weeks
it was weird and that was during the
time where
some Poltergeist [__] had happened it
ripped some [__] off the [__]
trim off the top of the dam
covers
through the remote in front of
the front of Jenny and Jen and Dimitri
friends of ours
they saw it and I was just kind of zoned
out at the time
and my mom was there she saw it she was
like did you see that my mom knew about
the Poltergeist but she never saw it
her her sister Lois saw it she didn't
really believe us until she saw that
she's like she was doing that a lot it
man I was like yeah
every few minutes it would do stuff like
that
yeah
I [__] once I kind of came to I was
like wow I did move that didn't it
I stood up and [__] fell all the hair
on my phone
here in the back of my [__] head I
had hair back then
stand up like that it felt a [__]
energy go down my [__] spine and like
fear
you know [__] looked up like that and
I felt like it was coming back and I
looked down there was a stack of coins
in my face at my feet
which made sense at the time
because I said I wish it would do
something useful like bring me some
money it brought me some money but it
brought me that was that was from a
[__]
nightstand
your Poltergeist is a smartass yeah I
mean the money from the nightstand you
should have specified an amount I wanted
a pallet of [__] unmarked hundreds
from the [__] bank yeah I want how
about that yeah I don't need a bunch of
[__] quarters oh [__] I'm gonna go
get some Fritos out of the [__]
machine yeah Poltergeist
I want to never have to work again I
want to retire I want enough money for
that yeah bring me that it was weird
[__] please and thank you but yeah so um
so yeah so TV comes on a couple times
that night and she's like oh okay maybe
it's power surges but still like creepy
later on that night though
she's kind of sleeping and she hears
something like Whispering her name like
in her room now at first she thinks it's
Anna her daughter so she sits up and
she's like what but she doesn't you know
she goes in Anna's room and Anna's still
sleeping and then she goes back in bed
and then she hears it again and then she
realizes realizes that it's actually a
man's voice like saying her name and
she's like no man in the house so I
don't know who the [__] that is I would
probably [__] my pants thinking it was
somebody that have broken in I wouldn't
immediately jump to ghost I would
immediately jump to rapist or something
you know what I mean yeah but yeah so so
at this point she's like okay I'm pretty
sure this shit's on it I think that that
was when she came to that realization
so she calls up her mom now her mom was
also on the show talking like the real
lady
the mom's name was Renee Lopez I think
they said her name was
and so mom is like actually pretty
support supportive because they said
that the women in their family were all
kind of like mediums and like her
Victoria's Grandma had like always been
able to see ghosts and stuff like that
so it was kind of like a family thing
where everybody
kind of knew about it and all believed
in that kind of stuff right
now Mom advises you know because she's
like I'm pretty sure the shit's haunted
so what should I do and Mom says
probably just you should ignore that
[__] you know what I mean
um she's like but do a cleansing just in
case so she does the whole deal with the
sage and all of that business
so they said for a few weeks after that
um the house was completely calm like
nothing weird happened or anything like
that
but then
oh and this is this is sad I was bummed
out about this so they have it they have
a dog they have a dog and a cat yeah now
the dog's name I don't think they said
the cat's name the dog's name is Mozart
which that's adorable okay it was an
adorable dog too
um Mozart the dog started acting weird
like he was sick
um he wouldn't eat or drink like he'd be
hiding and stuff like that
so Victoria takes him to the vet but
they can't find anything wrong with him
like everything looks completely normal
and she's like we kept taking him back
and forth to the vet all the tests were
normal but it's like the dog just kept
getting sicker and sicker like he
wouldn't eat he wouldn't drink it's like
he seemed like he was in pain all the
time because he was like howling and
stuff and they just couldn't figure out
what the [__] was going on and so
Victoria was like maybe you know I
farted around up there in the attic and
like you know Unleashed something
unwittingly by touching other people's
[__] I don't really know
um and they ended up I'm sorry to say
having to put Mozart down because he was
in such pain and they couldn't figure
out and there was no autopsy huh not
that they mentioned I mean yeah they
didn't mention that I mean it could have
just been there's a lot of [__] that
could be that's what I mean so see
that's what I mean there's like a lot of
this stuff is kind of like when you lay
it all out like in a Litany of stuff
like that yeah it sounds like super
creepy and everything like that but if
it happens over like several months or
something a lot of that is probably just
like coincidence could have swallowed
something ahead
some kind of an intestinal blockage
might have eaten something that had a
damn wire in it metal wire that'll [__]
you we've seen that remember that when
people eaten the wire bristles that's
exactly what I what I thought of when
you said that like that [__] what was it
called Monsters Inside which sometimes
was like about diseases like you'd have
like tapeworms and [__] like that but a
lot of times too it was about like
random [__] that you swallowed they
didn't know about and one of the ones
that freaked me out the most and just
happened more than once in the series
and it's happened more than once in the
series is somebody will like though you
have to go to a summer barbecue or
something like that and then they're
like [__] stomach is all [__] up
like one dude started this is gross so
I'm I'm just warning you ahead of time
but one dude started like throwing up
[__] yep
um and it turned out that he had
swallowed
um a wire a wire bristle off of a grill
brush yeah which had been stuck if
they've been cleaning the grill with it
and it got stuck in a burger or
something like that stuck on the meat
and he ate it without knowing and it
like poked a hole in his intestines or
something like it went down his
intestines got lodged in there it stuck
through it like a needle and then the
food couldn't pass through that it was
just cracking up in there oh my God
that's got to go somewhere and he's
[__] farming it up [__] fecal
matter and [__] I was like we are never
cooking anything on the grill ever again
[Laughter]
cards of testing and not found anything
wrong because that's not cancer there's
nothing wrong it took him a long time to
figure it out you would have to have to
go in there and X-ray and go Mass
intestinal blockage
probably what happened to the dog
something like it swallowed something
and it couldn't
it couldn't [__]
yeah killed it
and they didn't have the money to
[__] do the test that is a horrifying
probably what it was I mean I used
something along that line we used to
watch it like sometimes like in on the
weekends like sometimes we would sit
there for hours and just like why just
like binge it it's like and they were
just like and I'm just like this is
horrifying and disgusting and yet I
can't look away
[__] I'll give you a [__] um mental
problems it will because you'll like
think about like I said I was just like
holy [__] now there's another thing that
I have to worry about you clean the
grill with the grill brush yeah I'm like
okay we're getting a plastic girl
although I don't know if that would be
anything I don't think they make those
Grill brushes I don't think they do I
don't think they do either because it's
happened more than once every grill
grill brush I've got my hands on was
plastic now yeah not metal which yeah
yeah like I said with swallowing a sharp
plastic thing be any better though yeah
I mean I guess it would be because it
wouldn't it wouldn't be as sharp and and
you can't really digest plastic but
softer
straight out people have swallowed all
kinds of plastic before without any ill
effect you just crap it out
you just crap it out yeah
[Laughter]
there's a bunch of [__] that you can eat
you wouldn't think you could eat it I
mean you could eat it without I mean
don't don't eat it there's a lot of
stuff people have eaten I just pass it
out later yeah
but yeah that is like a little bit
swallowed a Hot Wheel car one time and
he just passed it out you shout out
shout out the [__] [__] out a Hot
Wheel car remember that can you imagine
that being your kid and you're this is
that little car this is your mom and
just like this is my life now I have to
wait here for this [__] kid to poop
out [__] Hot Wheels car
we need to wait [__] my life anyway he
just it just I know but I'm just saying
it's just like that so kid had to
[__] probably drink [__] vegetable
oil move that [__] up man right Zach get
that
I got you Zach
Jesus Christ how do we get on these
topics
[Laughter]
yeah well because we were talking about
poor Mozart the dog all right people
Mozart yeah
so then I found out too like after the
dog died they also had a cat and I was
like oh no nothing bad ever happened to
that cat it's bad enough that like
little little doggy died but um they say
they said a month after the dog died
like the cat started acting weird too
like I started acting the same like real
sick and everything and at this point I
mean good for the lady she like put her
foot down she's like okay I'm not like
losing my cat too on top of all of this
so they didn't even say what the cat's
name was which I thought was kind of I
was gonna say racist but it's nice
[Laughter]
so they didn't say it but the cat didn't
die as far as I know as far as I know
they they got out the [__] out of there
before like something bad after the cat
because they saw something was happening
to the cat and they were like okay yeah
that's not happening so um basically
what she's now see this is another one
where I think the people did the right
thing where they were just like look
this [__] up [__] has happened in this
house the dog died and whether or not it
had anything to do with the supernatural
whatever that was going on I don't know
but they believed that it did and
they're just like [__] this we're not
hanging around we're not losing the cat
too it's like I'm done with this [__] so
they moved
um and they moved from Indiana to New
Mexico uh because New Mexico was where
Victoria's parents lived so they went
out there like to live near her parents
they were like yeah we're just gonna try
and get away from this whatever the [__]
this is
so Victoria ends up getting a job in
Santa Fe like um as a lab tech or
something like that and when they first
get there a month goes by and nothing
happens so they're just like oh good we
escaped this whatever the [__] it was
however when I wasn't clear did they
move in with her parents
I think it was her parents house and
then her and the daughter moved in with
the parents I thought yeah I wasn't even
following it at that level I was just
mostly keeping track of what the
phenomenon was yeah yeah I guess they
moved she moved into their mom I think
they yeah I think she would do it with
her mom and dad
um it's just it was confusing because it
seemed like at one point she went to a
house and like talked to her mom and I'm
like wait I thought they lived in the
same house what the [__] going on so I
don't know if they like live next door I
don't know I don't know
um but so yeah so she's in New Mexico
now
in the middle of the night
um someone starts pounding on the front
door
and Victoria said on the show like the
real woman she's like I immediately knew
what it was I immediately knew that that
[__] Supernatural whatever the [__]
had followed me like all the way to New
Mexico she knew it wasn't a person
and so she's like so she opened the door
and she's like sure enough nobody was
there it was just like pounding yeah we
had the doorbell ring in the middle of
the night yeah I didn't hear it Jenny
hurt she said it ranked twice and she
woke me up
and they'll be there what time was it
about three four it was four something
four four thirty something like that she
was [__] scared so you didn't dream
it she goes no no I was I was awake I
told you the first time I was awake okay
I knew that I heard it the first time
and I was like holy [__] I didn't think
it was a ghost I thought it was a person
and I'm like why the [__] is somebody
ringing the doorbell at 4 [__] 30 in
the morning that's never good I was like
that's like a [__] murderer so that's
what I thought
but I was like well maybe I imagined it
like after a minute or like or 30
seconds or something I'm just like well
it's possible I could imagine it I'm
like I'm you know 99.9 sure that I was
wide awake at the time I wasn't sleeping
it didn't wake me up I was already awake
and then I was like okay maybe I didn't
hear it I try to like talk myself out of
it but then it rang again and I was like
okay I know I [__] heard it that time
and that's when I woke you up yeah if it
hadn't rung again I wouldn't have woke
you I'll grab my Walther P99 yeah
because I thought it was a person yeah I
had a 40 caliber ready I was [__] I
thought I lived down there trying to
look through the window to see if
there's anybody at the door because I
didn't want to go to the door
yeah because what well I mean the door
the whole of houses and [__] you know
well that's what I was thinking the door
in the old house was glass like in front
of his glass like we had like blinds
over it but like you could still see out
yeah and you could kind of see in a
little bit like around the sides and so
I was thinking I didn't think like I
said I didn't think ghosts the first
thing I thought was that's gonna be one
of those situations where somebody comes
up and it's like help there's been an
accident and then like you go and open
the door and then they [__] and five
guys and then they bust in yeah that's
what I thought yeah I was kind of
thinking that too
so I was trying to look at look at that
there were Windows to see the door there
was nobody at the door there was nobody
there and then I [__] went to the
door itself and [__] looked out
through the people and opened it there
was nothing there
and he came back and says there's
nothing there it was pretty creepy
I believed her though
I had to ask are you sure you want to
sleep she said no it was like no I was
scared I was awake before the first one
yeah but I questioned myself that's what
you do and I think about a week before
that happened the garage door opened in
the middle of the night by itself it did
yeah yeah that happened more than once
but I remember no that only happened
once I did it yeah it only happened once
yeah oh and the girl and the door from
the garage to the garage to the laundry
room got opened open by itself yeah
that was weird
just open one which it couldn't even
open that way yeah my [__] hair stood
up I was like whoa we were looking at it
yeah because I was like
um that's not right I said that doesn't
yeah but during that time when the TV
was turning on it only closed you
couldn't and that's the thing like if
you were bringing in groceries like from
the garage for example you had to like
wedge something under it because it
closed yeah so it wouldn't open like
that
it was an eerie time
it was when we were writing the book
yeah and a little bit after like we were
doing a lot of interviews and like shows
about it that's why
murder Hornet said I had someone knock
on my door in the middle of the night
here and nobody was there yeah that's
like [__] weird
[__] weird but yeah so but it's
interesting to me that she said before
she even opened the door when she heard
the pounding that she knew
that it wasn't a person
like she just had a feeling that it
wasn't a person that's what she said
so she's like so she sits in the living
room of the house and she's like
eventually it stopped
now a little bit later she's at work
like I said she's a lab tech and she
starts like spacing out and she gets
like a nosebleed and it looks like she
kind of like fainted or like went
unconscious for a minute and started
having seizures
so she said these symptoms that she
started having like started in March I'm
presuming of 2006 but I'm not entirely
sure like right around that time
and then by the time November rolled
around she's like it just kept getting
worse and worse and by the time November
rolled around she was just like really
really sick and like couldn't even
[__] function anymore
so her mom said they had like tests done
like over the course of a whole year she
kept going back and getting tests for
every single thing they could think of
and they couldn't find anything and
she's getting sicker and sicker and
she's starting to think to herself you
know these are the same kinds of
symptoms that the dog had and so so
she's starting to think maybe that it's
like some kind of Supernatural like it's
I don't know like it's like she didn't
say psychic vampire but it's something
that was kind of like draining her
energy or like making her sick like a
negative energy or something like that
that's kind of what she was implying
because no one can figure out what's the
matter with her
so um
at one point too like a little bit past
that she's in her room sleeping and she
said she kind of half woke up and got
the feeling that someone was watching
her and then she turns and sees like a
real scary like demon dude essentially
he was like standing in the doorway and
the doorway or in the closet door or
something like that and he just kind of
had like a he you know he looked like
the standard a haunting demon dude like
with the robe and all that yeah the cow
all over his head because that's he had
his hoodie yeah Supernatural demonic
Hood demonic hoodie yeah yeah that's I
mean I need one of those you need a
demonic hoodie yeah you want me to make
it one no I'm gonna buy one from shin
[Laughter]
they got one
it's all sleeveless and everything it's
got a hood you see that that [__] I've
seen ones like that yeah they got she I
was looking Sheen had some nice ones
they were only like [__] six bucks
there you go yeah gym stuff you can have
all kinds they got the [__] gym pants
and everything [__] uh for booty
booty pants Zach could love that [__]
I don't think I can get that back arch
that Tom Hardy had you gotta practice I
gotta practice yeah can you be down
every [__] taking pictures I'm gonna
have to like that push your butt yeah
I was like come on that's funny
[Laughter]
well you know
you're always telling me you're always
telling me to do that like to practice
like sticking my butt out and stuff like
that you gotta get you gotta go so you
got to do it too if I gotta do you got
it if I gotta talk to you Showtime's
gonna be here soon man
it flies up once the only fan starts up
and we get [__] stream mate going
you're gonna have to be twerking man you
have to we're gonna twerk lessons
well both credits
I want you to twerk too especially I
gotta tell you well yeah especially
because hey you you bought those [__]
jockstrap things yeah underwear with
your little ass hanging out yeah so I
was like I'm afraid you're gonna have to
work at this that's all right that's
funny and I'm gonna videotape it yeah
have people critique that right sure
just look at your twerking technique
trouble if I got myself into hey this is
your idea what is my idea
you know what a terrible person I am so
I don't know why you even agree
I could come up with all kind of crazy
[__] you don't even want to get me
started I've had too much to drink
and a lot more than me I'm only just
sipping because I'm like you know I'm
trying to talk that [__] was strong I'm
halfway through it yeah I mean I made
mine really strong too but I've only
like drunk a little vodka punch man
yummy this Publix like punches public
punch wow it's their generic punch for a
whole two liter like a dollar and ten
dollar and 10 cents and it's like I
don't know if you guys are old enough
remember remember Tiki punch it's like
that
it's like Hawaiian Punch but it's
carbonated
it's good it's great mixer
it is very good yeah it's good with [__]
it's good although I'm gonna say like
pretty much everything's better without
candy yeah it's good it's good with
silver tequila in it too man real good
so uh so yeah how much left have I got
left you got some not not a lot
because it's super messy I have you know
it's I have really really neat
handwriting but I'm trying to like write
fast so it's like this looks really
messy sometimes it's so messy that it's
like I can't even read what I wrote and
I'm like wow that's shameful but yeah so
um seeing a demon dude in the in your
bedroom which you know that's a little
bit alarming so of course she was just
like [__] terrified
so over the next month she just keeps
getting sicker and sicker and she said
she just kept looking for a rational
explanation finally one doctor says I
was like was it Dr house because he said
maybe it's lupus and I guess nobody had
checked for that that's kind of the joke
about that show house was that he would
always no it's not lupus but yeah so
they asked if it was lupus and she
hadn't been test for that and it's like
well that's kind of what your symptoms
are like has anybody asked you about
that and she's like no actually nobody
has said that so they gave her some
medication for lupus and she's like and
she seemed like she was getting better
but then when they did the test for
Lupus it was negative so she's like
whatever but the medicine did seem to
work to some degree
so then at some point she starts hearing
like she's in the house and she hears
like this little girl like giggling like
in the hall or some [__]
and then it turns out that Victoria can
now see ghosts like big is life or
biggest afterlife I guess so she sees
like these two kid ghosts like standing
in the hallway like a little boy and a
little girl and she said they I mean it
was scary but she said they weren't
menacing they were just kind of like
standing there kind of looking at her
questioning like what like you can see
us wow that's crazy like just that kind
of thing
um now at this point she's still trying
to find a rational explanation which you
know more power to her she's like maybe
the medication they're giving me for the
lupus is like making me hallucinate
which yeah that's probably the first
thing you would think so she does a
bunch of research and calls all the
doctors and they're like no that's
usually not something that that
particular drug does so she's like okay
guess it's not that
uh three nights after that she actually
goes out to The Kitchen in the middle of
the night to get a drink and sees a
female ghost like a woman and kind of
like an old-fashioned like a big ass
dress and stuff like that
um and she kind of like turns and like
vanishes right
so at this point Victoria goes to her
mom and tells her you know I've been
seeing all these ghosts pretty much uh
you know so what do you think I should
do about that mom says maybe the ghosts
that you're seeing have something to do
with starvation Peak which I guess is a
story that a lot of people around this
area it's like near Santa Fe I think
which I've been to Santa Fe but I don't
remember hearing about this story before
but um apparently the legend goes
that or the history goes that there were
some there was a Native American Hunting
Party
and the all the men went out hunting
and there was a group of settlers that
came into the the village and killed
like all the women and children like the
the American Indians
and so
the Native Americans were mad you know
understandably so they're like okay well
what we're gonna do is we're gonna drive
all these settlers like they trapped
them up on this mountain that's that's
called starvation Peak now and they're
like if they come down we're gonna kill
them and it's like we're just gonna
leave them up there until they then like
starve them out like hence why it's
called starvation Peak so they said
everyone around there like knows this
Legend and mom is like well maybe that's
why there's so many ghosts around in
this area because of like all of the you
know bad [__] that happened around here
although like I said bad [__] happened
everywhere you'd think this place would
be [__] crawling with ghosts because
you know there's all kind of terrible
things have happened like over the over
the centuries
so uh mom figures well I'm gonna smudge
the house again just in case you know
you can never be too sure
so then they said stuff quieted down for
a little bit but then
um there was like a what is that what is
that word that I wrote down
closed something
open by itself
closet door
closet door closet door open by itself
okay I guess that's what that says like
I said I have really neat handwriting
but when I'm trying to write really fast
I don't know what it says because I'm
trying to do like shorthand you know
what I mean
um and then the demon [__] guy is like
um he's all growling and [__] and he
like jumps at Victoria it seemed like he
was like wow like he came at her but
then like
she was like holy [__] but then it was
gone you know what I mean so it was that
kind of situation so she's like okay I'm
not sleeping in this [__] bedroom
anymore so she just like goes and sleeps
in the living room
and then the next morning she's getting
dressed for work and she's like man what
the [__] is up with my back like it's
stinging she said it felt like acid
poured on it and then her mom looks at
it and there's The Telltale three
scratch marks so you know it's demonic
because that's always how that is only
three fingers yeah only three fingers
that's what you know what I mean
yeah it's always it's always three
and they it's funny too because they
always have like the demonologist or
whoever like very authoritatively like
telling you it's like that's how you
know it's demonic when it's threes and
I'm just like okay I'm sure you really
know that but okay
so um so at this point you know they're
like yeah all the prayers and sage
smudging and all that [__] like we did
didn't work obviously
so they decide what we're gonna call
some paranormal investigators and see if
they can sort some [__] out
now evidently what happened was Victoria
said that she contacted a bunch of
different paranormal investigators in
the area so I'm assuming she just like
emailed them or called them and left
messages or whatever but she said like
most of them would not respond to her so
like a month or two went by and it's
like she didn't hear anything back like
nobody wanted to help them like I so I
don't know I don't know if they were
just busy or they didn't
so finally though there's this group
called Purple Sage the real the Purple
Sage Paranormal Society I think is what
they were called
and they call her back and they're like
okay well we'll try and help you out so
they want for some reason they didn't
really uh explain like their reasoning
for this but they said they wanted to
meet with her at first off-site
so they said they met at a hotel and
like talked to her about the case I
don't know why they didn't go to the
house immediately but I don't know they
didn't really explain like why they did
that
now it turns out they didn't actually
say this until much later in the show
but Victoria
um had actually done
uh uh three tours in Iraq she was uh in
the Marines she was like a medic which
like I said they didn't really mention
that at the beginning but they did
mention it here
so she's at the hotel
talking to the Paranormal people
now one of the Paranormal people is a
psychic sensitive woman and her name is
Denise
and she says that she feels like there's
something in the house that's like
sucking out Victoria's energy right
and then the psychic in the hotel room
starts feeling
kind of shitty like kind of starts
feeling kind of sick
and then she also says that she's nobody
else sees them but she says she sees a
little boy and a little girl ghost and a
woman like and described like the outfit
she was wearing
and then Victoria said holy [__] I
didn't tell her any of that but she
described the ghost that I saw in my
house like I said I don't know if it's
true or not this is what she said
the psychic also says she sees a
quote-unquote darker Spirit uh which she
described and she's like yeah that's the
same one that Victoria has been seeing
now another member of the paranormal
team whose name is Roger also starts
feeling sick like a couple minutes after
Denise does like they start getting like
oh like they're like all nauseated and
everything
so they figure well you must have picked
up some [__] like back in Indiana and it
followed you to New Mexico
another thing they noticed too was they
had like an EMF meter going like Roger
did and there was a spike on the EMF
meter and he's like and when the spike
went away like he said everyone started
feeling better like the sickness went
away
so the investigators they said we don't
usually do this but um because of the
weird [__] that was going on was like
well can we come to the house right now
like we want to see what's going on you
know right now
so when they got to the house they said
from the outside they couldn't really
feel anything they said it actually
looked really Pleasant and peaceful and
everything like that but then once you
get inside it was kind of like a
different story
now the team tells Victoria they said
just show us around the house like you
were showing it to a real estate agent
or something don't talk about the
Paranormal [__] because we don't like
want them to know that we're here or
like what our intentions are or anything
so she's just like kind of showing them
around
so what
I'm talking I'm talking to Bill remember
uh he's answered that question we had
that problem with that video you know
the resolution came out
it was magenta magenta's long wavelength
yeah like magenta had it been red it had
been a little bit different so the
colors has to have a lot to do with it
well especially if you're up at [__]
like 4K
he says this three thousand dollar
camera has problems in a low light to
some of these weird colors
yeah I mean it's funny how to have a
phone could kick a kick a camera's ass
though isn't it funny well yeah yeah
[__] on my phone comes out yeah and my
phone is like a super cheap old phone
yeah it's like not even a new one yeah
it's not her fold old but her phone
takes beautiful [__] photos
seriously I take pictures of that phone
like selfies and stuff like that
especially with the new lights and stuff
I don't have to do [__] to him I'm like
holy crap that looks amazing he says run
white lights on it was slightly dimmer
than the color
lights got to be bright too especially
for 4K yeah I mean for a video is
different like I said for the Selfies
when I'm really close to the camera yeah
like I like that soft pink light I think
it looks really good but
you know what I mean but for a video you
need brighter light and especially if
you have like
you know maybe those cameras don't like
have a good little late setting
uh Ben said a funny thing he said there
is a reciprocal haunting agreement
between certain States when you move
from one to the other Spirits are able
to transfer to your new property that's
how that works out yeah he was just able
he's like oh you guys are gone I'm going
to I'm going to it's the rules
but um but yeah
so they said well while they're in the
house they said they're just doing the
preliminary walk through today they're
not gonna like do anything crazy or
anything
um which is why they didn't want the
ghosties to like know that they were in
there but they said regardless of that
um the psychic acoustic was Denise and
the other guy his name was Roger they
said they definitely felt like the
entity like moving past them and Roger
said because the real guy was on the
show and he's like and it wasn't subtle
either it wasn't just like a little ooh
I felt a little it's like you know your
hair blew back and everything like that
like the whole like the dude like was
like you know and then he took a picture
because Denise said oh he just came
through the bedroom and went into the
bathroom over there and Roger took a
picture of the bathroom like he kind of
went around the door frame like that and
like took a picture into the bathroom
and apparently they didn't show the real
photo they showed one I'm assuming that
was just like a you know a fake one
they made for the show but Victoria said
the picture that he showed me looked
exactly like the thing that I saw all
the time like the Demonic oozes
so
I don't know I don't know what the real
photo looked like but they said that it
turned up in the photo
so make of that which you will
so a few days later the investigators
turn up to do their thing
so they send Anna away they send the
parents away Victoria's still there
so they start out in Victoria's parents
room so like I guess it is all they do
all in one house
because they said that's where it seemed
the safest like they didn't really have
any reports of any activity in that room
so they start using I love this they
start using what they call light source
communication because they have to give
everything like a cool sounding name
this is essentially you just putting two
flashlights in a room and asking the
flashlights questions and supposedly the
ghost is supposed to turn the flashlight
on
for yes or like make it blink two times
for yes or whatever like however you
have it set up so the ghost is supposed
to turn off and on the flashlight to
answer your questions so it's basically
like an EVP but like an even more cheap
Jack version but I just like think it's
funny that they call it light source
communication but it's literally just
like a flashlight you're asking
questions to a flash yeah you have a
technical [__] yeah we will go to a
light source communication yes that's
right Roger activate light source
you got a Spock down there we are now
communicating with the entity
light source communication activator
yeah yeah and he gets like the [__]
flashlight off of his key ring yeah
right and then he's like here put that
over there now it has to go some [__] oh
it came on may I have your tricorder Mr
Sulu
it's just I don't know they it's just
it's funny to me how they make
everything sound like more big and epic
than it actually is light source
communication yeah talking to a
flashlight is right here so I mean you
know not not to be an [__] I'm just
saying
uh now you beat a NASA no I'm just
no it is it is I know I don't care
technical terminology for [__]
talking to this goes through a
flashlight through a flashlight yeah
yeah so um I mean the theory behind it
is that ghosts find it very easy to turn
flashlights off and on so they're trying
not to like strain the ghosts
um you know energy like you're trying to
wear them out so I guess it's easy for
the ghost to turn a flashlight on and
off so
okay that's well you know I don't know
yeah they're just they're just making it
up I don't know so they said at first
they're asking a bunch of questions to
the flashlight they actually used two
flashlights I'm not really sure why they
didn't explain why they needed to
but um maybe maybe uh just so like well
because it's like if it was just one
they could argue that it's like oh maybe
that was just like glitching out or
whatever but if it was like two of them
they're like oh well if both of them are
coming on and off at like various times
then you know that it's like Paranormal
or whatever I don't know that's just my
that's my idea I'm not really sure
but so they said that at first they're
asking the flashlights like all of these
questions and nothing was happening
which you know is not really a surprise
but then Denise and Victoria both of
them
sensed that whoever or whatever this
entity was didn't like Roger for some
reason
I don't know what's wrong with Roger he
seemed like a perfectly nice person but
okay
so um so yeah they don't like Rogers
they're like hey Roger you know get the
[__] out and we'll see if he'll talk to
us like when you're not here and then we
can talk about Roger like what maybe the
ghosts wanted to talk about Roger like
while they were gone but yeah so they
tell Roger to leave the room and they
said that as soon as Roger left the room
then when they started asking the
questions of the flashlights then the
flashlight started like answering and
like lighting up and stuff
so basically this the flashlight ghost
said that it had been with her when she
died
um and that it it had followed her so
that they confirmed like what they had
thought like it had followed her to New
Mexico
and what they presumed like from asking
the flashlight the questions was that
when uh Victoria died on the operating
table
like she brought a hitchhiker from the
other side much like the Haunted Mansion
at Disney World where they always say
that you're gonna have like a hitchhiker
at the end and it's like sitting on your
head and [__] like when you're leaving
so it's kind of like that except [__]
well one of them was like like yeah last
time I went to Disney with my sister
like a couple months ago like there's a
little one that was like set up on the
on her head I thought that was kind of
funny but yeah so
this is like hitchhiked from the other
side because he's like hey I'm gonna go
back over to the land of living and [__]
some [__] up I don't know
Denise felt that this was
um a very angry dude who had done bad
things when he was alive now in I don't
know how they knew this exactly well I
guess she's psychic okay so that's like
her story and she's sticking to it but
um in the reenactment they made it look
like the dude was like a gang banger
like he was just like hey I'm shooting
people in a drive a drive-by and [__]
like that you know what I mean so it was
that kind of crap I don't know if that
would have had anything to do with
anything
um and that he was maybe in like some
kind of like purgatorial kind of
situation and then like when he was just
like farting around in the in purgatory
and then he's like hey here's this lady
that is kind of dead for a second and
then like maybe she's going back to life
there was like shoot I'm just gonna
latch right on and I'm gonna go back to
The Living World and [__] around for
some reason I don't know
so they asked they found out like from
the flashlight that um I don't know
the flashlight told them that um or I
don't know maybe maybe the psychic just
came up with this but she said that the
ghost that um that Victoria had been
seeing like the two kids and the woman
it's like they didn't follow her like
they're like what happened when she died
and then when you came back it was just
you know it was like a sixth sense kind
of situation where it's like you died
you came back to life and then you can
see ghosts now although he didn't the
kid in Sixth Sense didn't die first he
could just see ghosts anyway but um but
yeah so she's like well they they were
just here so you can just suddenly see
them they didn't follow you or nothing
like that but um so they decide to try
and send the [__] ghost
like into the light like they're all
gonna help him out because they're like
well
they didn't they didn't think it was a
demon even though they kind of hinted
toward with the three scratch marks and
all that that they were gonna go in a
demonic Direction but to their credit
they didn't do that they didn't call in
the church they didn't do nothing like
that they said this was that this was a
person this is like the ghost of a
person he was just a dick you know yeah
dude so it was like he was just an
[__] ghost
so they're like but we can still help
him like everybody like the psychic said
I believe everyone can be redeemed and
can go into the light and bloody blah so
she's like so we're gonna help him out
so they all like get together and do
like a prayer circle or whatever the
[__] and then while they're doing that
like the flashlight starts like
flickering like crazy and then Roger is
like well it started flickering it's
like so we weren't really sure if like
the [__] ghost was mad at us or if it
was because he was like happy that we
were helping him or we weren't really
sure because I guess the flashlight was
just flickering back and forth so Denise
tells Victoria well you're the one that
lives here and you're the one that he
latched on to so you're the one that has
to tell him to get the [__] out like he
doesn't belong here and it's like tell
him to piss off like into the light like
a good ghost and that should be the end
of it so then they do this whole like
dramatic thing where they're saying all
this stuff and then the flashlight keeps
flashing and on and off on and off on
and off and then like it suddenly stops
and then energy dissipated the light's
not flashing
um you know she said felt like a
weightlifted offer blah blah
so ever since that which again a little
anticlimactic this didn't have like a
big exorcism with like [__] [__]
flying around or anything like that it
was just like flashlight going on off
pretty much
um but since then Victoria said she
hasn't seen the [__] ghost but I
haven't seen that [__]
that's funny well I mean if you got to
be haunted by a ghost yeah I mean that
kind of sucks when you'd be like this
would be like that's all goes you want
like a nice ghost that'll help you out
and [__] but um Mrs Muir yeah we're like
he was hot yeah it's like why don't you
tell me later is like wash my dishes or
something like he was hot and he waited
for her yeah
but she said so she doesn't see the
[__] anymore so he presumably went to
the light and bloody blah and now he's
fine he went to heaven and got forgiven
and yada yada
but um she still sees the other Spirits
like all the time and like the massacre
ghosts like they're assuming
um and it's like yeah I mean I guess
they can stick around because they're
not causing any trouble and they're not
causing her into any distress they're
not doing anything she just sees them
um however she said she does wish that
she could stop seeing him though because
it is like kind of upsetting which I
which I can I can understand that but
you know what I mean but at least she's
not seeing the demony goes like popping
out her closet anymore going like ah you
know what I mean because that's a
[__] that's the shitty thing to do to
somebody you know why would you spend
your afterlife doing that
I ain't worried about it
that sounds like that sounds like some
[__] you would do no
after you were dead you're just I'm
gonna go [__] with people I'm gonna go
[__] with people I'm not sure you know
I'm not sure about this case there's to
me there's not a lot about it it's
compelling
just
that was her experience that's their
story you know
me personally I I don't think there's I
don't think there's much to this
I just got a weird feeling about it
well now a lot of it was subjective
subjective stuff yeah
um you know other than a few things like
the knocking and
maybe the children not a lot of
witnesses the helicopter coming on by
itself and [__] like that but yeah it
seemed kind of minor like a lot of it
was you know and a lot of it could have
been coincidence like the dog getting
sick and then her getting a helicopter
could have been coincidence or it could
have been technical right issues with
that yeah possibly so I don't know I
just
I just kind of think it's a weak case
now that the near-death experience might
be real but she said she didn't see
anything
which that was really interesting to me
that she just said because she would
think
in a way that sort of made her like I
don't know if I believe this story
either but I'm saying in a way that sort
of made her more credible because you
think that she could pick something up
that she would just make something up
like if she was kind of gunning to be
like oh I brought a hitchhiker back with
me from the afterlife I was went to hell
and I saw a thing there and then when I
came and then when I came back like it
was like [__] around in my closet
that'd be even a better story right but
the fact that she said I didn't see
anything yeah in a way kind of makes her
more like me believe her a little bit
more true right you know that part that
part might be true the rest of it might
be misidentification I don't know I
wasn't there yeah
this was a case where it was mostly
subjective you'd had to be you would
have to be there
you know to know yeah and she's like the
only one seeing the ghost really
like other than the psychic saying that
she saw them too and like described them
the same you call a psychic into the
scene man they're gonna tell you
anything that's yeah that's I'm always
kind of like skeptical event
John Gore said I wouldn't be a
malevolent ghost I'd just hide things on
people like their keys while it's coffee
cups Just for Giggles [__] it's you
doing that
now we know we know who's doing this
[__]
because that happens to me all the time
although I just thought it was because
I'm dumb and forgetful and like I put
[__] down I'm just like where the [__]
one second think she's dumb don't doubt
well for one second think Jen's done
Jen's [__] sharp as attack
yeah not much gets past me well I don't
know about that but yeah some [__] gets
past
most [__] doesn't get past yeah most
[__] doesn't get bad to me
Jen's pretty sharp you think oh yeah
hell yeah
look at Pookie try to get underneath the
damn cat uh she's trying to go
underneath wait a minute I gotta see
that trying to go underneath the rug huh
there's nothing under there she thinks
there's a damn Cavern in their cave
gonna go in the poop You're Gonna Go the
Pookie cave okay
all right so this is that that's it for
this this case so yeah that was the end
of it that was the end of it all right
so we can talk about some other stuff or
we can wrap it up [__] we've probably
been on for longer than an hour we can
go ahead and wrap this up hour and 20
minutes usually an hour and 20 minutes
that's how long we've been on all right
so oh well bye
okay okay spooky was trying yeah well
every now and then like you'll come into
the room like where the rug is and
you'll just see her little butt sticking
out from underneath the rock like she
loves going or anything and then you
pick it up and she's just like what yeah
Ben says I have to run anyway catch you
all later okay so um
so it's Monday right yeah so taking the
day off tomorrow uh at least from live
streaming yeah Wednesday night show oh
this should be a fun one we should have
a [__] blast with this I've been
wanting to do this topic for a long time
and it finally won in the poll best
stories from the weekly world news I
don't know that one oh you don't know
the weekly world news I knew The
Enquirer
the weekly world news is way better okay
this is I know what you're talking about
you know the one that's in the grocery
store thing that it's like they don't
have it anymore it's like grandmother
wouldn't buy yeah she wouldn't buy that
one because that's all [__] then
shoot well done but she would buy The
National Enquirer and she would buy the
sun we'll see the national I didn't even
actually know this but the the weekly
world news was actually I think it was
the same publication company as the
national enquirered but they just well
what they did was win the National
Enquirer in the 70s when it went to
color like when they went to color
printing they still had the old black
and white press and they're like we
can't just waste that so like let's
print this other thing and then like
they had the idea to just like print the
most [__] ridiculous [__] imaginable
that's like you know but I had a I had a
baby with a big foot and it was an alien
yeah yeah yeah and so it's all like very
very big on Bigfoot stuff alien stuff
Elvis sightings yeah mermaids that's
kind of a big thing they went on a big
mermaid tear
um you know Armageddon type of stuff and
of course the infamous and Immortal
batboy
um you know who's he's like the he's
like their spokesman at this point and
it's like I'm gonna have to I'm gonna
have to sift through because I was
looking at some of the covers like
earlier today I'm like oh my God there's
like so many I don't know I know what
you're talking about I don't know how
I'm gonna pick I used to buy it every
now and then just it was super cheap it
was like 25 cents or something what was
entertainment like back in the 90s and
it's like if they had a really good
cover like Hitler was a woman and it's
like and then it would have like this
really bad well it had this like a
really bad Photoshop of like the top
half of Hitler and somebody had just cut
out like the the bottom half of like a
skirt and like some bumps and it's like
they just kind of pasted it together
well because the whole aesthetic of it
was like they don't really want it to
look real but remember this the whole
thing was they wanted it like all the
stories they're like you have to write
them as if it's absolutely true see I
remember even though they were just
making them up I remember it from like
the late 70s early 80s that's when I
remember it it started in 79 okay I feel
like it's Heyday was like the 80s and
90s right yeah it stopped um I don't
they didn't do the print they don't do
the print one anymore like since um 2007
I think they stopped doing the print
version but they still have a website
but most of it like you can still go on
the website and like see all the
headlines and like the first paragraph
and stuff but I think it's behind a
paywall now but they still have some
great [__] headlines because I went
to the website today and I was like oh
my God this is so [__] great there's
like this it's like it must be so fun it
must be like the funnest job do they
have Chuck tiggle working there yeah oh
Mickey they should they should recruit
him recruit Chuck tank I mean he could
be for all we know because that's not
his real name obviously so that might be
Chuck tiggle right for that [__] that
would make sense because he comes up
with some crazy [__] too
everybody everybody Jack you ever read
Chuck tangle
my billionaire airplane boyfriend oh my
God yeah powdered in the butt by my own
book pouted into butt pound it into butt
yeah that he had a whole like that was a
whole series yeah well the first one was
wait
what [__] okay unicorn General the gay
unicorn my gay unicorn General boyfriend
yeah he was like go no the ghost of my
gay unicorn boyfriend General [__]
it's just oh dude's amazing I mean it's
just kind of this fun all you have to
you don't have to read the stories I
mean I advise you do because they're
like really funny but you can just go on
the Wikipedia page and read the titles
of his books and he'll bust up and
you'll just like bust up laughing it
will make your day yeah because I'm just
like oh my God I love that this dude
they're like Harlequin romance novels
for insane gay men pounded in the butt
by my own butt was the first one I think
pound it in the butt by my own butt yes
right and then basically he's [__] in
the ass by my own ass and then that's
the name of the book damn and then there
was a sequel yeah like after that book
got really popular like he wrote a
sequel that was called pounded in the
butt by my book pound it in the butt by
my own butt yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
I think there was a third one but I
can't remember it got like really
constantly
and I couldn't like remember but it's
like he was really good at like coming
up with [__] like that yeah yeah having
sex with Dinosaurs gay dinosaurs yeah
he's real big on unicorns dinosaurs
Bigfoot Bigfoot um airplanes yeah like
anthropomorphic airplanes yeah yes your
boyfriend is a billionaire airplane like
it like yeah he's an airplane and he's a
billionaire
and he's solving all your problems yeah
and pounding you in the butt
hahaha
it's just uh insane insane one of my
favorite YouTubers who is Dominic Noble
he actually did a video because he's
like is Chuck tingle actually a good
writer so he like picked a whole bunch
of Chuck tingle books and actually read
them to like review them and he's like
you might be shocked to hear this but
these are actually like very well
written and like really entertaining
which uh you know you wouldn't think
like you would think that it was just
like a page but it says Chuck Tango it
shows a picture with the author and it's
just a generic photo of a dude in a
karate ghee yeah [__] red and I've
seen some too where it's just like a
stick man like a drawing of a stickman
or something like he's but like I said
it's genius it's genius marketing oh
[__] we're getting free money well hey
Jeffy art hey guys been a while but been
busy with my weekend job still listening
to you when I come home oh okay thank
you that's good thank you just trying to
get trying to get you all through the
work day yeah that's what we're doing
yeah yeah Ben says world uh weekly world
news was an institution Joe Berger was a
genius yeah I agree too some of the
[__] I mean I just remember the
photos and the some of the headlines the
headlines are [__] great because like
I said I was looking at a bunch of cover
today because I said oh my God how am I
ever gonna like narrow it down because
so many of these are so [__] funny I
remember in the 80s me even as a kid
reading that [__] knowing that that was
just a joke an entertainment I never
read any of it but I'd see it in the
checkout oh there's mine just go yeah
that's [__] they're super fun but
they had people that would buy I guess
it's just humor yeah yeah I'm sure there
are some like dumb [__] out there that
actually believe some of that shit's
true but um
most of the time sure most people it was
just like me like that I just thought
that was funny as hell like I said
because like I said it used to be only a
quarter like back in the 90s I think it
was a quarter so it's like like I said
if it had a good headline like
chocoholic mom gives birth to
sugar-coated baby and I'm like [__] yeah
I'm gonna buy that that's [__]
hilarious I used to have like back in
the 90s I had like a big collage like on
my bedroom wall and it had a bunch of
covers from that because I would always
buy one if it was funny or it had like
funny pictures on it
my grandma would buy a [__] The
Inquirer so she could find out what was
going on with that dude from The Price
is Right what was that guy's name
[__] um Bob Barker Bob Barker I'll
tell you what was going on with it I
love [__] Bob bark he was grabbing
women's asses without their consent
that's what was going on yeah old women
my grandmother's [__] Generation Love
Bob Barker yeah my grandmother did they
all had fantasies about him and [__]
yeah and he was just some old man you
know but he did he looked like a
televangelist he did it a bit yeah got
the handsome guy with white hair
surrounded by beautiful showroom model
type girls not quite as creepy as
Richard Dawson but Richard Dawson was
creepy but he was cool because he was
drunk yeah that's true yeah that's true
what's he doing all right what is she
doing over there pulling [__] books
is she pulling all the books out of the
Shelf she's like you guys are not paying
attention to me so I'm over here like
she'll find [__] Blu-rays on the
floor she's pulled him out of the dam
yeah when I go over there like a
bookshelf she pulls out the same she
pulls out Darwin's Origin of Species
yeah I think it's a big thick one yeah
like a couple eggs that are on the
bottom she pulls them all out because
we're not paying attention and I'll be
walking down the hallway catching her
and she'll run by the [__] Blu-ray
[__] shelf and go and she'll knock
four or five of them out and run like
she didn't do it I saw you do it and
then she died no you did not I was there
I was over here the whole time [__]
fine she's so sneaky you think you're a
child you're not a child
she is a child though she's a tiny furry
child yeah and she's she's very
recalcitrant also all right so we'll be
back Wednesday talking about weekly
world news so I'm really looking forward
to that we'll have some drinks and talk
about like the [__] crazy [__] okay
that sounds good so yeah that'll be
super fun so that'll be that'll be nice
for a change not doing a depressing
topic all right so thank you everybody
for dropping by this evening and have a
good day tomorrow we will see you guys
again on Wednesday night